all right good afternoon
and a warm welcome to all of you here
with us in Warsaw and watching us via
live stream from around the world I am
Aisha to say and it is my my great honor
to moderate this important conversation
bringing together leaders and champions
to raise urgently needed funds for those
directly impacted by the invasion of
Ukraine I'm joined by the co-conveners
of today's pledging event president
Ursula vondeline and prime minister
Justin Trudeau who is joining us live
from Ottawa we're also joined by
President Andre Duda
and we have with us Hugh Evans CEO of
the advocacy organization Global citizen
which mobilized a worldwide social media
rally just yesterday to Galvanize
support for Ukraine and later we'll be
hearing from Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski who sent us a special
message from Keith
I also want to mention some special
guests friends from Ukraine who just
very recently were welcomed to Poland
they are from Kiev they're from hakive
from dinipro they are mothers they are
daughters grandmothers and Sons they are
displaced but they are not discouraged
and we are here for you today
now before we begin our program I'd like
to invite your excellencies my esteemed
colleagues in the press and our guests
to please join me in a moment of silence
in remembrance for the lives lost since
the invasion began and in recognition of
all refugees and displaced people around
the world
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
president of the European commission you
are the co-convener of today's pledging
event and I'd like to thank you for your
leadership and ask you to open the floor
first please
yes thank you so much
um it's wonderful to be here with you
here with you Mr President
um with you Justin wonderful to have you
here indeed
um I was yesterday in Keith
and I visited bucha
and there are no words for the horror
I've seen in butcher the ugly face of
Putin's Army terrorizing people
and I have so much admiration for our
brave Ukrainian friends fighting against
this they are fighting our war it's our
fight that they are in because it's not
only
Ukraine fighting for its sovereignty and
integrity but they are also fighting for
the question whether Humanity will
prevail or whether he needs Devastation
will be the result it's the question
whether democracy will be stronger or
its autocracy that will dominate it's
the question whether there is the right
of Might
dominating or whether it's the rule of
law and therefore this is the reason why
together with Justin Trudeau with Hugh
Evans and thank you very much Mr
President for hosting it here we said
they stand up for our freedom so we
stand up for Ukraine this is the reason
why we're here today and it is we want
to Rally the world for refugees inside
and outside Ukraine to support them so I
hope that many many people will join I
want to thank Global Citizens for really
activating and mobilizing so many
artists Sports people celebrities Mr
President I want to thank you for
hosting us because this is the country
that is hosting two million refugees
from Ukraine so many people are here who
support thank you very much for that and
let's have a fantastic result for
Ukraine
thank you thank you president Wonderland
prime minister Trudeau we are very
grateful to have you with us today and
for Canada's support of this effort Mr
Prime Minister you have the floor
thank you very much
thank you for joining the stand-up for
Ukraine pledging event I'm so pleased to
be co-convening this important event
Ursula we've been intensely working
towards this event for a while now but I
need to pause for a moment on your
leadership and your commitment to
protect those in need which demonstrates
such a strong compassion and a strong
presence of humanitarianism we can
always count on you to bring people
together and I want to thank you for all
your hard work and for uh everything you
did with your visit uh to Keith
yesterday highlighting just the
atrocities but also so much The Human
Side of this war
I also want to thank president duta of
Poland and Hugh Evans CEO of global
citizen for helping make this possible
we're here today to answer president
zielinski's call for the International
Community to mobilize in support for
Ukrainian refugees and all ukrainians
Vladimir Putin's War has created a
humanitarian crisis
I was in Warsaw just last month I met
people that had left their homes with
only a backpack it was all they had for
their most important belongings they
shared incredibly difficult stories with
me they don't know when they'll return
home to their husbands their sons their
fathers they don't know what the future
holds
because
I also want to thank all the artists
entertainers athletes and everyone who
participated in the stand up for Ukraine
social media rally yesterday if you
haven't already you can still make a
contribution by visiting for ukraine.com
your voice donations and advocacy are
making a real difference you're helping
provide food Water Shelter and Medical
Aid for refugees who had to flee their
homes so thank you my friends as a
humanitarian crisis deepens and needs
continue to grow our Collective response
must keep Pace that's exactly why we're
gathered here today together let's keep
working to mobilize governments Around
the World Private companies and the
people in our communities to support
refugees from Ukraine and indeed support
all ukrainians
thank you Mercy prime minister Trudeau
when the invasion of Ukraine started her
neighbors in the EU and countries like
Moldova did not hesitate to offer safe
harbor to the masses of people who fled
according to the latest estimate Poland
has taken in more than 2.5 million
refugees offering basic necessities like
food shelter and medical supplies
president Duda we thank you for your
leadership we thank you for the
generosity of the Polish people the
floor is yours
thank you very much
Madam president from the Lion
prime minister Trudeau Dear Justin dear
friends from Global citizen
distinguished artists
dear friends from around the world
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for organizing this meaningful
event and
dear Madam president thank you very much
for your presence to in Kiev yesterday
really important and that was a visible
symbol of the presence of European Union
in this in this in this in our
neighborhood very important for us for
Polish people and I hope also very
important for
European union and not only for European
Union countries but also for all the
Democratic and just countries around the
world
it's symbolic that we are meeting here
in Warsaw Poland has been a front line
Century this country in the face of the
Russian war against Ukraine
in so many respects my compatriots have
been the first to help
thanks to them Poland is a country where
the largest number of ukrainians have
found home
I'm glad that my dear friend president
of Ukraine involves zelinski is joining
us today
he is an example of a true leader and
the hero of our time
this event is another site of
international Unity we all support the
same values peace freedom democracy and
the right to self-determination
today we stand up for Ukraine but at the
same time Ukraine has been standing up
for us
ukrainians are fighting not only for
their freedom but also for hours
today we are supporting millions of
Ukrainian refugees and people in need
above all we are sending a message to
every single Ukrainian in the cities and
Villages Under Siege
a message of Hope to the brave Ukrainian
soldiers Heroes defending their country
from the aggressor
dear brothers and sisters
You Are Not Alone
much has been done however in near
future Ukraine will require huge
economic boost similar to the one
offered to Western Europe after World
War II a new martial plan for Ukraine
this is why today's initiative is very
much appreciated I'm glad that the
Polish government with its Partners is
planning to follow up and organize an
international donors conference for
Ukraine
a Polish music icon
Yemen sank and I quote let's viense
foreign
but there are more people of Good Will
and I do strongly believe that this
world will never die thanks to them end
of quote
and so it is
so many people of good will have been
standing up with Ukraine today's
spectacular event has sent a powerful
message in this regard once again many
thanks to the organizers
Long Live Free Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you
thank you president Duda
since February 24th the eyes of the
world have been focused on Ukraine and
we've been horrified by the brutality of
the invasion and inspired by the
resilience of the Ukrainian people and
as we've seen over the last 24 hours
with the stand up for Ukraine rally and
today's pledging event the world stands
with Ukraine let's hear now from
president zielinski 45 days of a
full-scale war and defense against
Russians today
the attack by the largest country in the
world the largest by its territory the
largest by its aggressiveness the
largest by its impunity
Russian leadership failed to account for
one fact the fact that it attacks the
other largest country in the world
Ukraine the largest by its currents with
not afraid of massive missile strikes
Russian aircrafts and never-ending tank
columns Ukrainian currency has inflicted
heavy losses on the rush in Soldier than
during the previous Decades of regular
Wars Ukrainian Carnage has already
United the whole Democratic World
millions of people in different
countries are witnessing our currents
the people from different countries know
about our bravery it shall always be
remembered in history but I would like
Ukrainian cars to be shared by everyone
in the world just as we are defending
ourselves again the greatest tyranny of
all so the other people of the world
should bravely resist this tyranny they
have to do everything to force Russia to
see peace they have to do everything to
hold Russian soldiers and they are
commanders accountable for their crimes
against the Ukrainian people
sanctions must be imposed against all
Russian Banks Russian Oil Embargo must
be imposed the Russian war crimes
machine should be denied its capacity to
act vital assistance should be provided
to Ukraine we have asked for weapons
we've asked for financial assistance we
have asked for support to Ukrainian
negras for those 10 million people
forced by Russian to flee their homes
the demographic world had the power to
help Ukrainian courage deserves respect
convince your politicians stay with
Ukraine stay with freedom stay with
bravery
[Applause]
very powerful words there from president
zielinski Ukrainian courage deserves to
be respected and as we've heard this is
a fight for democracy over autocracy
um
yesterday Global Citizens brought the
world together online in a social media
rally that reached all parts of the
globe and as we've seen throughout
history when art and activism combines
what emerges is a powerful force now
this campaign called on leaders from all
sectors to stand up from for Ukraine
um Hugh Global citizen has been
campaigning from the very beginning for
refugees and those displaced by this
invasion in Ukraine can you tell us a
little bit more about your efforts and
some of the highlights of the campaign
well thank you Asha and thank you for
moderating today's session and I also
want to acknowledge those incredible
words of President zielinski I think we
can all agree that in facing down this
enemy with such courage president
zielinski does so much more than defend
his own Homeland he's defending the very
basic tenets of a functional
International order
and that's why we must not look away we
must do everything within our power to
stand up for the humanitarian issue that
is the internally displaced people
within Ukraine and those refugees who
flee Ukraine a few weekends ago I was on
the Border Town of Medicare and I saw a
young woman with her children crossing
the border and she struggled to carry
the bassinet that was in her arms and
this in today's Summit and today's
Gathering is all about making sure that
that woman when she gets on that bus has
a safe place to go with a place to sleep
that night where she feels safe
where she has Health Care food security
and the hope that her child when they
grow up will have a great education
that's what today is all about and so I
want to start by thanking president
vondoline I want to thank prime minister
Trudeau for co-convening their
leadership has been absolutely
extraordinary and I commend you from the
bottom of my heart I also want to thank
you president Duda our sincere gratitude
for hosting us today and to the
generosity of the Polish people because
you've shown such generosity and
solidarity with the people of Ukraine
excellencies members of the press
and also those who are gathered with us
today
I really want to thank everyone for
their support of Global Citizens stand
up for Ukraine campaign as the world's
largest movement of citizens taking
action for the eradication of extreme
poverty we have been working on this
since the beginning firstly to mobilize
government and the private sector to
increase their financial support for the
refugees and internally displaced people
but secondly we partnered with president
zielinski on a daily call to action that
has now been viewed by over a billion
people around the world just in the last
few weeks yesterday thanks to the
incredible support of artists athletes
creators and all of those around the
world the stand up for Ukraine's social
rally called on world leaders today
to pledge the billions of dollars
necessary to support refugees and
internally displaced people
the videos were shared by incredible
people such as Oprah Elton John Billy
eilish Annie Lennox U2 Celine Dion Pearl
Jam Bon Jovi Bruce Springsteen Hugh
Jackman Priyanka Chopra Jonas Madonna
and so many more
and in total yesterday there were over
three billion impressions of this
campaign but it's important to realize
that this is just the beginning our work
is just getting started and we have to
view this
as a marathon not as a Sprint so today
we look forward to seeing the amazing
responses from world leaders and from
the business community and I want to
share with you now a brief overview
video of yesterday's campaign thank you
I'm Oprah Winfrey and I'm joining Global
citizen to say a deep and heartfelt
thank you to all the countless Advent
allies we're volunteers who donated
who've spoken out who risked their lives
and stand up for Ukraine the refugee
situation here is bad a lot of people
still
it's one of the fastest large-scale
displacements of children since World
War II
the Ukrainian Border in Mexico standing
up for Ukraine leaders around the world
I'm standing up for Ukraine so many
people in the UK are incredibly Keen to
help in any way they can but they [ __ ]
the government those people who are
leaving their homes and their loved ones
need more help we urgently ask or plead
with our governments to commit big money
world leaders we need you to answer the
call from the activists and Advocates
working to support refugees contribute
the billions they need join me and the
WWE universe and stand up for Ukraine
I'm Casey Musgraves and I stand with
Ukraine and refugees around the world
[Music]
Slava Ukraine
Slava Ukraine
Slava Ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
behind
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
to create a powerful force for Ukraine
president dudes unable to stay with us
for the entire event but we want to
thank him for his presence today Mr
President we will allow you to leave we
know you have a very busy day ahead
thank you thank you so much for your
presence today
thank you very much
[Applause]
the climate Justice and political
activist originally from cave she
recently fled to Warsaw
um I really thank you thank you for
taking time out of your day to to share
to share your story with us can you tell
us what the last couple of weeks have
been like for you and your loved ones
so basically I'm Marina belay I'm 16
years old I'm based in Kiev but right
now I live in Warsaw I fled my country
and I fled my city due to war initiated
by Putin but still fueled you know by
whom but by some of those who are
sitting right now with me at the same
table and where those with those who are
also hearing me right now and watching
me right now
the war didn't started at 24th February
and you have to understand it the war
started eight years ago and Russia
invaded Ukraine eight years ago and all
these eight years world was completely
fine with fueling this war with having
business with with Russia with this
cruel regime with bloody regime and for
me as a Ukrainian and for other
ukrainians it was not a surprise that
the war hit we were like preparing in
some way for it
and
because we know that the world now is
based on a system which makes people
like lower than profit and money goes
over that's why this business was going
on and the system now is empowering
autocracies that's why we knew that the
World will hit
so
Arena help us understand how important
it is to get these pledges now and the
difference that will make
you know that I'm a climate Justice and
political activist for three years and I
started my way when I was 13 years old
because I saw like this world is
literally burning and we are all okay
with it we are all ignoring it
we are all doing or or just ignoring or
doing some fake actions and we're not
doing like we're not trying to approve
this system we're only trying to solve
the consequences and we're here now also
about it
well Arena we thank you for
for capturing the passion and and and
and just summing it up as you know as
this what impacts you and your loved
ones and and so many there in Ukraine um
president borderline to turn to you
um Europe has come together in an
unprecedented way to support those
coming from Ukraine to the Block You've
activated
um the protection mechanism and offered
direct support to Ukraine itself can you
tell us a little bit more about those
efforts to date
um you know as you stand in solidarity
with Ukraine
yes indeed I mean uh there are four
four million people that fled Ukraine
right now in the European Union and they
are 6.5 million people with uh in the
within Ukraine who fled the war and they
need help they need help
they need urgently help here in the
European Union it means um that we've
immediately triggered the protection for
them that gives them citizens rights so
from day one on access to schools to
housing to health care and of course to
the labor market but of course they need
much much more they need support the
member states are doing an outstanding
job it's phenomenal the ngos are working
on the ground the communities the local
communities are outstanding in receiving
the refugees but as I said more is
needed and any pledge will help a
refugee here in the European Union but
also and this is so important any pledge
will help a person that is internally
displaced so lost their home because of
the bombing and shelling of Putin's Army
within Ukraine yesterday when I spoke
with President zielinski he urged me
again to first of all ask for pledges
for you train refugees in Ukraine but
also to be very clear for those who had
to flee Ukraine that they are welcome
here it's wonderful to have them here
and we want to give them shelter and
support and help as much as possible
but president zielinski was also hoping
that pretty soon you might be able to
come back and help rebuild the country
what I want to say is that Europe stands
by your side and I know Justin Trudeau
I've spoken with him many many times
about times about addressing to a fully
determined also with Canada We Stand by
yourself be it now in the times of War
be it with the refugees but most
importantly after this war has been won
by Ukraine for the time for
reconstruction and rebuilding the
country so our motto is really Slava
Ukraine
thank you madam president
um prime minister Trudeau turning to you
now this crisis has once again shown a
light on the unimaginable circumstances
that women and girls find themselves in
times of conflict and this conflict is
really again reminding us of the unique
challenges that women and girls face in
these moments separation from their
families gender-based violence as a
weapon of War all of these things come
into play so let me ask you this in your
view what interventions do we need right
now to deal with this issue in the
context of Ukraine but more broadly how
do we tackle this issue of gender
equities
thank you so much first and foremost one
of the things we've seen in so many
different contexts over the past years
whether it's the climate crisis that I
think you know for bringing up whether
it's the covid crisis or whether it's
Vladimir Putin's illegal war in Ukraine
women and girls and the vulnerable get
hit disproportionately hard but are also
a disproportionate level of the solution
we need to bring forward we need to make
sure that looking at the horrors that
are coming out of bucha the use not just
of violence against civilians but of
sexual violence specifically against
women as a way of trying to crush the
Ukrainian Spirit Ukrainian identity we
need to stand incredibly strong to make
sure we're protecting women and girls in
this that's why Canada not just in
regards to Ukraine but all around the
world has a feminine feminist
International System policy that
recognizes the protecting women and
girls is one of the best ways to support
not just getting through a crisis but
also rebuild afterwards that's where we
need to lean in on preparing for the
future and it just to highlight Ursula
has spoken so strongly and and we've
seen uh uh Andres Judah and others talk
about how welcoming and how important it
is for Europeans to be standing up and
supporting the millions of refugees in
Europe but I've spoken with leaders from
around the world who recognize that this
crisis is having impacts around the
world uh either directly on on
humanitarian sites but also in standing
up for the rules-based order the
principles the U.N Charter sovereignty
of countries these this is a time for
all of us to be standing together and
doing the right things uh and that is
why I'm so glad to be representing uh
the World As We co-convene this uh this
conference with Ursula
Mr Prime Minister thank you thank you
thank you for context there
on from what prime minister was just
saying about gender inequity we've also
seen in this conflict in Ukraine racial
inequity come to the fore um in the
early days of of this crisis as Millions
fled thousands of international students
also left
um Ukraine among them were were
thousands of Africans and Indians who
were in Ukraine studying
um and we we all read and saw the images
of the struggles that they face as they
try to get out of that besieged country
what are your thoughts on what needs to
be done to ensure that in these moments
of Crisis governments don't pit the
marginalized and um the vulnerable
against each other at a time when really
Collective Humanity should take
precedence
well thank you for your question Aisha I
think that um firstly we saw early on in
this conflict a scandalous double
standard in the way that
some refugees from other races
backgrounds Creed or color were treated
and I think that rightly so people were
justifiedly outraged at that it
shouldn't have happened and we know that
the refugee experience is universal
thankfully as president bondoline
outlined the EU has said that refugees
fleeing from Ukraine can live work and
study across the EU block and I think
that arena in her comments was touching
on something really important I started
my activism Journey when I was 14 years
old in the Philippines and I lived in
India for a year when I was 15 and I saw
in India that we need to address these
issues systemically not just as a result
of charitable gestures and so the rules
that we're seeing apply here need to
become the rule not the exception to the
rule for other Refugee crises around the
world what we need to see is that moving
forward this becomes the standards for
all of those who are fleeing War due to
say violence or persecution or climate
change as you as you highlighted
irrespective of race religion Creed or
color
and this worldwide Refugee crisis from
Yemen to Afghanistan is grossly
underfunded if you consider that in
Yemen they've received just a billion
dollars of the total four billion dollar
package requested or in South Sudan less
than 10 percent of the total 1.2 billion
dollars needed now what does this
underfunding mean It ultimately means
that kids don't get access to school
there is chronic malnutrition that
persists
and so we have to ultimately hold world
leaders accountable to make sure they
live up to their International
obligations I was saddened recently when
the UK government decided to slash five
billion dollars from their foreign aid
budget it's not necessary you know we
know that at the same time the UK
government initiated enormous bailout
for people during covert it's time that
refugees get that bailout
here thank you so much for that and
Arena I want to say thank you once again
for joining us today and again our
hearts go out to you your family and all
that your countrymen are facing right
now we stand with you thank you I've
also shared something may I go ahead
we have not only find
structural
um decisions to what to deal with have
to deal with consequences but we also
help to see the roots of this system and
now the system is paid based on fossil
fuels and it's based now on buying them
and you are now fueling this war Europe
is now fueling this war world is doing
it
35 billion euros since 24th February
yeah 1 billion for Ukraine it is
definitely a company
elections and we are here today to stand
for Ukraine and Arena we thank you we
thank you so much the system the system
of fossil fuels now as we know today is
a pledging event and thanks to the
efforts of our co-conveners and the
efforts of global citizen which
Amplified
um the call to Stanford Ukraine we have
seen global leaders stand up to show
their support take a look now at some of
their messages of support and financial
commitments
as impossible as it might seem War has
returned to Europe
we witnessed Terror death and
destruction we hear and see increasing
reports of unspeakable war crimes
against the civilians 4 million people
are fleeing while they can in speed
unknown in previous crisis we need the
world to Stand United to stop the war
and help Ukraine face a terrible
humanitarian emergency
I'm very proud that the European Union
responded to the Russian aggression
quickly and United today we are pledging
an additional almost 1 million euros
through the international Committee of
the Red Cross and world food program and
also as an in-kind assistance for
Ukrainian refugees in Moldova slack and
Poland we stand in solidarity with
Ukraine
Luxembourg extends up for Crane 2. my
government is fully committed to help
induce fleeing the horrors of the war in
Ukraine be there in or outside of the
brain so far we have been able to help
over 4 000 people that have fled the war
in Ukraine to find temporary and safe
home in Luxembourg as Belgian
governments we have decided to budget
800 million euro to be able to support
Ukraine and Ukrainian refugees going
from temporary shelter in Belgium to
humanitarian Aid in Ukraine and its
neighboring countries at this very
moment Belgian trucks are on the road to
Ukraine with medical assistance and food
we will continue our efforts as long as
needed Belgium will not leave anyone
Behind
These are times for solidarity courage
and kindness
we all hope for peace but until then we
stand up for Ukraine
[Music]
please speak a few words
you have our full solidarity
therefore Germany has pledged an
additional 425 million euro in
humanitarian and development assistance
for Ukraine and its neighbors plus 70
million euro for medical supplies
through the European civil protection
mechanism Germany stands with Ukraine
and side by side with all of you
Croatia pledges another 100 million
euros in assisting Ukrainian refugees
that we should be receiving in our
country in this dire times for the
Ukrainian people we will continue our
support our solidarity and our help in
these moments when we are standing by
Ukraine and ukrainians
foreign
the International Community and the EU
including Walter have welcomed refugees
fleeing from Ukraine with open arms and
supported the basic needs of those
suffering from the consequences of War
but
we know that much more can be done
Sweden will support Ukrainian refugees
arrived in Sweden with 300 million euros
I am glad and proud to be part of the
campaign stand up for Ukraine Slava
Ukraine
and today we could be to providing an
additional 1 billion euros in Loans To
Our member states
to support the longer term needs of
refugees and their host communities we
are proud to be part of the stand-up for
Ukraine campaign and join forces with
others to stand up against this war and
to contribute for peace in Europe
We Stand ready to do more in solidarity
with our Ukrainian friends
whose Invincible courage in adversity
that spars us all
as millions of ukrainians flee their
homes seeking safety we cannot be
paralyzed by horror
you must live up to the exemplary
bravery and resilience of the Ukrainian
people our plan is to make available by
end of 2023 an additional 4 billion Euro
financing
we will work on this together with
trusted partners and friends in Poland
and other EU member states to cushion
the impact of this unprecedented
humanitarian crisis
I think the organizers of the stand up
for Ukraine campaign Iceland is ready to
do more and the people of Iceland stand
with the people of Ukraine
the courage of ukrainians is inspiring
the world we stand with them in this
struggle in their struggle for freedom
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to all those fleeing the violence You
Are Not Alone around the world we feel a
strong sense of responsibility to help
the United States remains committed to
doing our part
foreign
I'm so grateful to see so many pledges
so many substantive pleasure Pleasures
rather for humanitarian and development
assistance to Ukraine it is now my great
pleasure to introduce to you Frank
katsudis who's with us here in Warsaw
and joining us shortly by satellite from
the US will be Carl henriks fanberg Fran
is co-chair of Global Citizens board of
directors and she's also Chief people
policy and purpose of San Francisco I
got it okay PPP and um Carl when he
joins us is I'll do a quick intro he's
representing the European private sector
community so he will join us shortly and
he also heads up the round table for
industry in Europe and he's the chairman
of Volvo we're working to bring him into
the conversation a warm welcome to you
Fran present wonderline to turn to you
once more we know that conflict is one
of the greatest threats to education and
according to UNICEF more than 300 150
000 children in Ukraine have already
lost access to education so Madam
president my question to you is this how
do we ensure that this doesn't become
the last issue that gets funded and that
we don't end up with a generation of
displaced youth with a lost education
and compromised Health yes indeed this
is one of the most pressing questions
because many many of the refugees are
young children and they need immediately
access to schools and of course children
lead other children so be with their
peer groups and therefore the pledging
here is also part of supporting the
member states who have refugees and
children I I was traveling to Keith with
the Slovak prime minister and he told me
that in the last four weeks they got 700
children that need immediately access to
kindergarten for example so it's just
also you need teachers you know
classrooms very practical thing very
down to earth and therefore it is so
necessary that we support them and that
but also health issues the the normal
Access to Health Care is important but
we have for example uh many that come
that are not vaccinated not only against
covet but also the basic vaccinations
um that you get normally in your
childhood so this has to be done
there are many that come
normally are not so present in the
population so the access to healthcare
is eminent extremely important all these
are topics where the member states are
really doing a great job and doing the
utmost to accommodate but the more
support they get the better and then
there is a last point I just wanted to
refer to Arenas last comment Arena
you're so right Arena wanted to tell us
rightly so that of course we are now
speaking about the refugees but we also
have to be very clear towards Putin that
this cannot be this aggression and
therefore we are imposing heavy
sanctions heavy sanctions on Putin and
his war machine to really dry out that
economic sanctions Financial sanctions
and arena is right what we have to do is
get rid of the fossil fuel dependency
from Russia this is far so important so
we got out of coal we are looking into
oil and Arena what we have to do is not
only diversify away from the Russian
fossil fuel but massive investment in
Renewables this is not only good for a
Strategic investment in Independence but
it is of also of course also good for
our climate and for our planet so many
many times to look at and I just wanted
to support you on that Point Arena it is
a very important one well you can be
sure
we are always grateful for The Bravery
of the young and to you that's what
Global citizen is all about activating
these Young Voices to get involved
um I want to talk to you about something
specific cue even before The Invasion
began we know that
um Global uh humanitarian Aid budgets
were already being strained that not
just human Aid budgets but development
budgets as well were under severe strain
after two years of the covid-19 pandemic
I've got to ask you again considering
this is one of the core drivers of
Global Citizens work how well this
invasion impact efforts to reduce
poverty and hunger and what must
governments do
thank you Aisha so I think firstly it's
important to acknowledge that during the
pandemic alone 120 million people were
pushed into extreme poverty as a result
of covid-19 even before this Invasion
occurred and we know that hunger has
been on the rise in the last four years
we know that climate change continues to
be one of these Generations greatest
challenges I believe alongside the
challenge of ending extreme poverty and
we also know that right now in Ethiopia
they're suffering from one of the worst
climate-induced droughts in decades this
was all before The Invasion and The
Invasion is going to exacerbate these
currently existing challenges at the
same time because governments are facing
so many competing pressures as we're
talking about you know pressure to
invest in this or this I think the
question we have to Grapple with is this
is really not a question of wallet it's
a question of will do we because we've
seen how governments can rally in times
of Crisis we saw it during the pandemic
where trillions of dollars were invested
when it was necessary and I would argue
right now it's absolutely necessary to
invest into the United Nations
sustainable development goals because
we're then investing in the future of
women and girls we're investing the
future of our planet and we're investing
in everyone's shared prosperity and
that's why I'm really proud to work
alongside prime minister Trudeau and
president Ursula of underline because I
think these are world leaders who
exemplify big tent foreign policy rather
than zero-sum thinking I think we need
to encourage leaders that really
encourage a big tent philosophy not a
zero-sum game where one person's benefit
is another person's loss this is a world
where we have adequate resources we need
to allocate those resources accordingly
and so I believe now is the time to
double down and as we head towards
really ongoing efforts to mobilize
Global Citizens around the world this
intersection between democracy and the
eradication of extreme poverty has been
stronger now more than ever we need to
really uphold and support world leaders
who invest in the future of our planet
much for that thank you as you said it's
not about wallet it's about well and I
want everyone to remember that and
there's more than enough money to do
this work
um prime minister Trudeau if I could
bring you in here the media
media driven news cycle
um
is driving the way we're consuming news
we've all seen the heartbreaking images
of hospitals being targeted in Ukraine
and we've read the many stories of
medical supply lines being blocked we
know that the sudden and the significant
flow of refugees has put strain on
Health Care Systems so I want to spend a
moment and focus on that and get your
thoughts on on how conflict impacts
Health Care Systems and what must
International governments do
uh thank you very much first of all one
of the things that we've seen over the
past years whether it was the covet
crisis or whether it's uh this war in
Ukraine
um everything's interconnected around
the world none of us are fully isolated
from impacts of what's going on
elsewhere that's why I thank you for
bringing up the uh the the sdgs the the
sustainable development goals uh from
the U.N I'm actually uh co-leading with
Mia Motley of Barbados a push to really
make sure that countries are buying in
fully on this with not just the money
but the will as as Hugh mentions uh but
we need to respect and understand that
the focus that Putin has had on
impacting civilian infrastructure
whether it's uh the train station we saw
recently whether it's civilians in bucha
or whether it's maternity Wards or
hospitals there is a deliberate attempt
to cause as much long-term damage as
possible to the Ukrainian people and
that is where the world not does need to
continue to stand up obviously we need
to be there to help heal the war four
wounds right now but we also know there
will be young people as Ursula talked
about impacted for decades by the
Violence by the horrors of War we need
to make sure we're there to build
resilience there to deal with the mental
health consequences as well of the
trauma of the loss of the grief of of
the fear that has been brought in that
stability uh that the world has started
to take for granted in many places uh is
now highlighted that it's not automatic
and we need to continue to be there for
each other even as we stand up for each
other and stand for Ukraine
Mr Prime Minister thank you thank you
I want to shift gears now and talk about
the private sector which has a big role
to play in moments of Crisis like this
one Fran if I could bring you in here I
want us to talk big picture and really
talk to me about how the expectations of
the private sector have changed among
employees customers and Society at large
over the last couple of years
thank you Aisha I think this is so
important so the first thing that I
would say is the issues that we're
dealing with are so complex that they
require the private sector to really
support and to partner with ngos and
governments I think one of the learnings
that we had throughout covid was that
companies found their way to really
focus on their employees their
well-being their health their Mental
Health
and this was a really important step for
us and I think the big question now for
companies is that same focus and
accountability that we have to our
people
can we get there where we feel that
accountability to communities around the
world and I think the most amazing thing
is that for many companies the answer is
yes and you see them showing up and
supporting and we see that here in
Poland and Ukraine which is beautiful
but there's a call to action for all of
us to learn what it means to be a
corporate Citizen and when we are a
corporate citizen I think what that
means is that we're focused on the
digital divide we're focused on issues
like education and how we can play a
role and especially now having four
million displaced people that that
really need our help we have to focus on
social justice and equality for all we
have to focus on the environment we have
to focus on the systems how we build to
a regenerative planet and I think that's
really the opportunity and for those in
the private sector that have stepped up
and there's so many I think we want to
say a huge thank you to you
and we need to acknowledge that there's
so much work to be done and that
together from a corporation perspective
we stand for Ukraine
thank you for that thank you and I'm
pleased to say we have Paul Henrik with
us joining us from the U.S uh thank you
so much for being with us can you give
us your sense of how the European
private sector is stepping up in this
moment
organized it might
be
here
who would have thought once again we
would see you
the president panels were who
I don't think it's either of our time
they're standing up for work call Henrik
apologies we're having some tech issues
with you so we're going to interrupt and
our apologies to all of you watching and
here in the room the tech Gremlins got
him apologies so we're going to move on
because you know building on what Fran
said and what Carl was building up to is
that the private sector is stepping up
take a look
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
google.org and Google employees have so
far provided more than 35 million
dollars in cash and in-kind donations
for the military relief and Refugee
support we're also providing the
International Rescue committee for
Grants a team of 11 Google Engineers
working full-time pro bono to provide
final information for refugees like
accommodation documentation and more the
tool is already available at United for
ukraine.org and there's more to come we
deeply appreciate your partnership and
your leadership in the second one
foreign
[Music]
six million euros to stand up for
Ukraine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
of its response to the urgent need for
vaccines
in a wrinkle time we have donated close
to 300 000 vaccines for Ukraine as well
as three neighboring countries
in addition through our sanofi
foundation we have been able to donate
essential medicines which added to our
vaccines donation can now amount to 22
million patients in Ukraine and
neighboring countries
we've also been proud to contribute with
cash donations amounting to 5 million
euros and we are now continue to stand
up for Ukraine to play our part with old
partners
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in collaboration with European Union in
our employees had donated tons of
humanitarian suppliers and we have seven
home available for those we come to
Spain
and I can announce today for the
donation of 1 million euros to
International Organization
[Music]
will remain committed to help
as you see that a whole host of private
sector companies stepping up Coca-Cola
Verizon Delta or making some kind of
significant pledges uh thanks to them
and also to Fran and Carl Heinrich for
sharing their perspective thank you
all right shifting gears once more about
a month before The Invasion started
Victoria mansca who's joining the
conversation now started an open source
startup but like so many other people
the conflict quickly put a stop to her
efforts so Victoria and her team shifted
gears and decided to focus on on
creating one of the first Refugee
centers here in Warsaw and today they
have five locations that are operating
here in Warsaw and the nearby radham if
I'm right and we actually had a chance
to visit one of the locations earlier
this morning and they are doing truly
incredible work more than a half a
million euros have been raised for for
refugees thanks to the effort of Team
Ukraine love Victoria thank you for the
work you do thank you for being here
with us the whole world is watching the
whole world is listening so let me ask
you this what do you want everyone to
know about the people you're helping
here in in Poland
um first of all thank you very much for
coming and I would like you to look
around
you're today in a room with strong
smart
incredible women who had to get away
from war who had to be dislocated and be
present and carry this niche of
supporting Ukraine from the outside
um over here besides the refugee houses
besides the enormous more than 400 tons
of humanitarian Aid which was supported
and sent to Ukraine we are actually
supporting as many Refugee houses as
it's possible we have already started
making the schools for Ukrainian
children and polish one in order to
bring the equality as there is no
difference between the children they are
all ours
um you know it is very important to
highlight that guys
we are union and of course with every
single bombing they are taken away the
leftovers of our Soviet past and with
every single child being educated on the
territory of European Union we're
becoming more united and all of those
children
will come back will build stronger
better Ukraine on those ruins of our
past
you know
I do believe that
pledging Summit is very important since
amount of work which we are currently
doing is it's so little I'm coming every
single day I'm speaking to those women
and I know that there is a lot of work
to do
so yes if we can support by simple
donation by simple simple story it's the
list
what is possible to do today thank you
for inviting me to speak oh you're
welcome
[Applause]
thank you so much for that Victoria
present wonderline
um to turn to you now
um many across the globe are becoming
increasingly aware of the wider impacts
of this conflict on the global food
supply in fact there are estimates of up
to 500 million people potentially facing
food insecurity as a result so with that
in mind what actions can the EU and the
European Community take to prioritize
this issue and basically
prevent or certainly minimize a global
food crisis
yes indeed I mean besides the incredible
human suffering that this war brings
along and
the unbelievable atrocities that we see
there are knock on effects for example
on Global Food security Ukraine is
basically the the wheat chamber of the
world
and now it is becoming more and more
difficult for the farmers in Ukraine to
sow and to have the next Harvest and if
you see the figures how many countries
in This Global South for example are
dependent on the export of wheat to
their countries from Ukraine it's a very
very serious problem and it is even even
more serious because yesterday the Prime
Minister Danish mihal told me in Keith
that Putin's Army is now systematically
bombing warehouses where grain and wheat
is stored or for example Ukraine needs
to export the wheat by by ships usually
so he's blocking these ships in the
Black Sea therefore increasing the
pressure on the food system so the first
thing that we've offered is listen
Ukraine then take the land route and we
will create so-called green curry doors
that these transports for a wheat can go
along through different borders it's a
longer land route but at least get the
wheat out and get some income in without
any difficulties through these green
Lanes we do everything possible to
support the Ukrainian farmers who need
everything to sew that they can do their
work in under very difficult
circumstances because of their safety
but they are willing to to risk their
life really to to produce to produce the
wheat that the world needs
um we are giving now 2.5 billion euros
into the global food security but I know
more will be needed because if I look at
the numbers I mean uh Ukraine is a major
part of the world food program for
example
um so this is one of the ugly knock-on
effects of this horrible war and one
more reason to do everything to end this
war Madam president thank you it's such
an important point she's making I was
listening to the BBC and they were
saying the conflict in Ukraine is
impacting Egypt because they depend on
bread and they're not able to get the
wheat and so prices are going up so
these are the Ripple effects they go
right across the world and that's why we
all need to stand for Ukraine and take
this seriously prime minister Trudeau to
double down on what Madam president was
just saying the world food program had
already warned that 2022 would bring
catastrophic hunger and that I'm also
learning and this I didn't know that
Rush Russia and Ukraine account for 12
percent of all food calories
so to have these countries now mired in
conflict and their importance to the
global food supply chain
what do countries need to do what does
the International Community need to do
to bolster hunger relief efforts
particularly to vulnerable regions
thank you first of all this just
emphasizes once again what a terrible
horrific mistake Vladimir Putin made in
choosing to launch this war because not
only is it causing horrific impacts on
Ukraine on Europe but as you say it's
affecting the world in my conversations
in terms of pulling people together for
this pledging conference but also just
Gathering support for Ukraine through
the U.N and elsewhere my conversations
with leaders in South America in Africa
in Asia across the global South there is
a deep deep concern that the energy and
security and specifically the food
insecurity that is being compounded that
as you say was already there for this
year but is going to get so much worse
requires us all to stand up and work
together supporting organizations like
UNICEF and particularly the word world
food program that is
heavily dependent on wheat from Ukraine
to try and replace that in countries
like Canada that can continue to grow
and grow more will need to do that to
compensate but it's going to be a very
very difficult year and I think that it
underlines how important it is that yes
we act to support people now in concert
in working together but also that we
understand that Global instability that
attacks like this on the sovereignty of
another country uh conflicts wherever
they happen around the war around the
world have an impact that goes far
beyond just the people and the civilians
in the line of battle it goes to our
entire global system where we have to
stop allowing conflicts and and and Wars
to undermine the progress the support
and the advances we're seeing across the
global South and around the world in
creating more resilient opportunities
for everyone this is a big step back in
the March towards a fairer world for
everyone that's why the world is coming
together not just in this conference but
in support for Ukraine uh and standing
against Russia's terrible terrible
decision
Mr Prime Minister thank you Hugh turning
to you since this Invasion began Global
Citizens message to world leaders has
been pretty clear immediately
immediately supported emergency food
response in Ukraine assist to all
refugees that are facing food insecurity
and ensure Global Food stability so can
you speak a little more about the
specific actions that policy meets
policymakers need to be taking in the
coming weeks on this on these because
they're not just one on these
interrelated issues absolutely and I
think that you've done a really good job
at already submitting the challenge
ahead of us so I want to focus if I can
just for a few seconds on three
practical Solutions I think the first
solution and uh prime minister Trudeau
alluded to this is that the world food
program have an urgent 590 million
dollar appeal right now to support the
3.1 million internally displaced people
those affected in Ukraine who are
currently facing food insecurity so
that's the first objective that we all
need to Rally around the second thing
that we can do is we need to open up
food stocks to ensure Global food supply
consistency and predictability and this
is particularly a message for the United
States and China to consider releasing
grain stocks to support humanitarian
efforts if necessary because it's the
only way we can create the sort of
predictability that's necessary to make
sure that markets do not fluctuate
because ultimately it's the poor that
pay the highest price and currently you
know we've seen all already a 12
increase in global food prices already
and the third thing we need to do right
now is we need to prevent 500 million
people from facing food insecurity
particularly across sub-Saharan Africa
by supporting small hot agricultural
Farmers to have the inputs they need in
ahead of the upcoming planting season
those three policy prescriptions I
believe will have a significant impact
on ultimately ensuring that we can keep
this issue under control while
ultimately there is an opportunity for
peace to Prevail in the water end
there is indeed much to be done here
thank you let's hear more now from
global leaders as they continue to
pledge their support for Ukraine take a
look
we also pledge to direct all react to
European Union funding available to
Ireland amounting to more than 50
million euro humanitarian purposes in
addition with our European Union
Partners we will continue to treat
ukrainians as if there were European
Union citizens
who must also look ahead when the war is
over we should rebuild what was
destroyed and make it better for the
heroic of Ukraine
we will not look the other way in the
last two weeks the government has set
aside new funds to help Ukrainian
refugees meet their everyday expenses
this means food medicines School
equipment
overall we've allocated roughly 500
million euros to support ukrainians
arriving in Italy and 110 million in
financial assistance to the Ukrainian
government
foreign
solidarity fund and other future
multilateral efforts
today I call home every country of the
Free World and all their citizens join
forces
we must all act United to stop the war
we're helping kind we track loads of
volunteering goods and protective
equipment we host an ever-growing
community of displaced ukrainians so far
50 000 including particularly vulnerable
groups such as orphans and patients with
severe medical needs but in the end what
Ukrainian people desperate in need and
what they deserve is peace
[Music]
I would like to announce a fresh and
symbolic Financial
[Music]
to support the humanitarian work
undertaken in the brain and neighboring
countries by the relevant agencies of
the United Nations
Denmark will continue to do everything
we can do to support the people of
Ukraine and your fight for freedom and
peace
speak for all of Denmark when I say we
stand by you and we believe in Ukraine
Slovakia commits 530 million euros to
stand up for Ukraine
Slovakia stands in solidarity with
Ukraine and as a loyal neighbor we want
to help both refugees fleeing the war as
well as the internally displaced persons
in Ukraine
those fleeing the war need a vision for
their future we pay special attention to
the integration of the refugees
we provide Ukrainian children easy and
quick access to schools and education
like this we help them integrate our
society these children get skills that
they will need in Ukraine in the future
when they will be rebuilding Ukraine
this week we made a national budget
decision to further allocate 700 million
euros for helping Ukrainian refugees in
Finland
ukrainians will withstand this tragedy
and once the war is over they will
rebuild their beautiful country with our
help we stand with your time
we admire the resilience and resistance
of the Ukrainian people we are now
welcoming Ukrainian refugees to Norway
my government is working hard to make
sure they are received and settled in a
good decent and hospitable way
Norway stands up for Ukraine as we all
should
millions of people have been displaced
either within Ukraine or forced to live
as refugees alleviating the impact on
them is one of our main priorities
today we pledge 1 billion euros of
support for these innocent citizens
whose lives have been turned upside down
recommend the immense solidarity shown
by Ukraine by Ukraine's neighbors we
stay ready to further support them
according to their needs and in close
collaboration with the EU
Estonia estimated over 1 million euros
in direct humanitarian Aid and today I
pledge 100 000 more
foreign
[Music]
Bahrain was one of the first countries
to provide humanitarian help for the
refugees in Ukraine through the United
Nations organization and that is our
King's strategy to take past special
action to provide the rescue support for
the not many people of Ukraine followed
by Fair visit where we will conduct a
live assessment of the situation and
provide necessary development assistance
and support
foreign
[Music]
for Ukraine and many of our leaders are
answering and we are grateful for that
as we begin to conclude our program
today
Hugh let me bring you in here in this
moment to share some of your takeaways
from what you've seen and heard over
this past hour and and your thoughts on
what needs to happen next
cool let me stop by saying
um a huge thank you to our co-conveners
president bondoline and prime minister
Trudeau for your leadership we wouldn't
be here today without your extraordinary
ability to reach out to the world and
bring everyone together so I think they
deserve a round of applause thank you
[Applause]
I'd also like to thank president Duda
and the Polish people for their warm
Hospitality in hosting us as well as
also acknowledge president zielinski for
his inspiring words all earlier and
thank you to you Aisha for being such an
extraordinary moderator you are amazing
and yeah
thank you
foreign I'd like to leave us with just
one clear takeaway and that is that this
is just the beginning of the process not
the end I think that once things leave
the headlines often politically it can
be harder and harder to fight for those
issues our job as Citizens around the
world is to keep the issues that matter
in the headlines and to ultimately drive
a movement of citizens committed to
those issues so my ask of all of you who
are here today because we are all
ultimately just family friends children
Sons daughters brothers and sisters is
I'd encourage everyone if you can make a
donation to support the people of
Ukraine I think Victoria said it so well
that this is an urgent thing where
everyone can do something if you can't
afford to make a donation please use
your resources or your company's
resources encourage your private sector
leaders to step up and ultimately all of
us have a voice so use your voice to
keep this issue of the Urgent
humanitarian crisis facing the people of
Ukraine and for refugees all around the
world front and center because
ultimately these are the values of
global citizen that ultimately we stand
for and I hope all of you will stand for
in your own lives thank you so much
[Applause]
prime minister Trudeau thank you again
for your leadership for the support of
the Canadian people and for being with
us today from Ottawa we truly do
appreciate you
the floor is yours for your final
remarks
thank you Aisha thank you all uh to
everyone who's contributed to the
stand-up for Ukraine event you're making
a real difference your efforts are
saving lives and of course Canada will
continue doing its part as well like the
other countries making announcements I
can announce a new hundred million
dollar contribution bringing our total
humanitarian assistance to 245 million
dollars since the start of the year
we'll also provide over 345 000
essential relief items like blankets and
mattresses to help those who need it the
most this is an addition the 620 million
dollars in financial assistance we've
already provided to Ukraine with another
one billion dollars in support still to
come for Ukraine's economic resilience
Canada is home to the second largest
Ukrainian community in the world after
I'm talking today from the Canadian
Museum of History you'll have seen
behind me at church well it's saint
anotheus's church which is a consecrated
Ukrainian Catholic Church that was built
more than a hundred years ago in the
Canadian prairies by some of those early
uh Ukrainian settlers who came to Canada
it's a reminder that Canadians and
ukrainians share strong historical ties
like so many countries around the world
Canada
foreign
continuing to look at ways to support
ukrainians who want to come to Canada
and need financial help to make it
happen we're leveraging relationships
with commercial airlines to organize a
number of targeted charter flights in
the coming weeks and will provide up to
two weeks of Hotel accommodation for
those who need it on arrival when
violence forces people to leave their
country rapidly it's important to make
sure they have what they need while they
settle into the new communities that's
why we'll set up short-term Income
Support to help and refugees get on
their feet
for working with Canadians provincial
governments and partners all over our
country to ensure ukrainians have a warm
reception when they arrive these are
efforts that Canada is doing but uh
countries around the world particularly
in Europe stepping up in all these ways
as well because this is a moment where
the world needs to come together stand
up for Ukraine and stand up for our
values and principles remembering that
everyone deserves to be safe so let's
continue to be there for each other my
friends and let's all continue to stand
up or Ukraine the values that we all
believe in deeply
foreign
thank you again for the wide-ranging
support you continue to provide to
Ukraine president Wonderland thank you
for everything you and the EC have done
to make today happen
um in support of those impacted by this
Invasion I'd like to invite you now to
share your final thoughts thank you so
much Aisha thank you very much for a
splendid moderation thank you very much
and many many thanks to you Hugh the
Global Citizens for again standing up
for those who need a strong voice
those who we often do not see do not
hear and mobilizing rallying the world
and pushing us politicians hard and the
leaders hard that's your job and it's
wonderful to see that and Justin many
many thanks for being a fantastic
co-host wouldn't have been possible
without you and thanks for your
determination whenever I meet you in our
G7 meetings for example example your
your intensity of your beliefs and the
the strength with which you are fighting
for the refugees and their needs I
really want to thank you for that
and when I look into this room here
I know there are many refugees here in
the room
and looking into your eyes and thinking
about your thoughts and the fears you
might have
I just want to tell you that we stand by
you I want to thank the citizens the
many many many people who just open
their hearts and their minds and their
doors and want to help you and comfort
you because they know
the question how we
today might one day also be a question
where they need help and then hope to
find citizens that open their minds and
hearts and doors for them
and therefore thank you
all for stepping up for Ukraine
I'm very curious what the pledges will
bring and you've seen many many European
leaders that have pledged for their
country we always speak of Team Europe
these are the 27 member states and the
European commission so we'll see what
the 27 member states have pledged but I
can only announce today for the European
commission that we want to pledge 1
billion euros
600 million of those will go to Ukraine
to the Ukrainian authorities and
partially to the United Nations so that
the Ukrainian authorities can who know
exactly who is in need can distribute
that and 400 million euros will go to
the front line states that are doing
such an outstanding job and helping the
refugees that are coming
and the final tally I think you are no
the boss no you are the boss you are the
president I am definitely not president
am I supposed to okay let me have a look
at the figures I see
so whoa whoa
we have finally
the world has finally pledged
9.1 billion euros through this campaign
and in addition hold on in addition the
commission working with ebrd adds
another billion for the idps in Ukraine
this is fantastic so 10.1 euros and if
you say that in dollars it's even more
[Applause]
high five
I I just want to say that again just so
that you'll hear one more time
10.1 billion euros and I just think that
deserves another round of applause
because that is tremendous
[Applause]
thank you thank you once more
excellencies members of the press and
our friends from Ukraine
but I want to say thank you thank you
for being with us here today thank you
for your time for your support
um to our friends from Ukraine I want
you to know that we will continue to
stand with you as you said these moments
they fall from the headlines but we will
continue to stand with you in this
moment to end our pledging event today
we we wanted to end with a song and this
was a song that was written 50 years ago
by John Lennon but performed in this
moment
by his son
Julian Lennon and it's a song that
symbolizes light at the end of a tunnel
so please enjoy Junior Julian Lennon and
Nuna Betancourt performing imagine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's easy if you try
no help in the West
[Music]
above us on the sky
imagine all the people
living for today
[Music]
imagine there's no countries
it isn't hard to do
nothing to kill all down for
[Music]
a new religion too
foreign
[Music]
ER
[Music]
but I'm not the only one
I hope someday you'll join us
and the world will be as well
[Music]
imagine no possessions
I wonder if you can
there's no need for greed all hunger
a Brotherhood of Man
imagine all the people
[Music]
you may say I'm a dreamer
but I'm not the only one
I hope someday you'll join us
[Music]
in the world will live this one
[Music]
so beautiful so beautiful and so
powerful thank you again to our
co-conveners and to Hugh Evans a global
citizen thank you to all of you that
concludes today's program thank you
for me
[Applause]
[Music]